one of the things I want to ask about is
using this thesis of kind of the mining
cell pressure walk us through what you
expect to happen over the next you know
call 45 days before the having what
happens at the moment of the having and
then maybe what happens in the three
months after the having and then kind of
eighteen months out so going into the
having absolute having three months
after and then eighteen months after
that yeah so we initially put this
report out to some to our investors and
clients in January so we were kind of
expecting the sell-off and we think that
bitcoin is probably in a trading range
and it'll continue to stay in quite
compressed margins for miners going into
habit now once we go through having the
miners revenue is gonna get slashed in
half this is one we're going to
experience what I call you know I think
it's going to be a healthy cleanse of
the network um we're probably gonna
experience difficulty adjustments of if
Bitcoin is still at eight thousand or
lower going into having we're probably
gonna this is when we're gonna get
extreme minor capitulation probably
thirty potentially forty percent of the
network shutting off anyone with power
above two cents running the whole
generation equipment is going to blow
out miners with mid generation equipment
like TT T's the NSL account machines
those are going to blow up if you're at
four cents or higher and individuals
running the the newest equipment at
seven and a half cents seven cents high
sixes they're gonna have to shut off so
I basically just listed off about 40
percent of the network nets in the
report we really lay all that out now
what is that it's not a light switch
people can't just turn off their
machines and they're not going to just
turn off their machines there's friction
you know people want to hope people are
in people have utility contracts where
they have to consume a certain amount of
power otherwise they they lose their
long-term contract they might be in
hosting facilities where if they default
on their payments
then there they lose their mining rigs
so if you just bought thousands of
dollars worth of mining rigs you're
going to keep paying your bill for two
or three months until you blow out
people are in facilities and they have
to pay you know their lease payments
they built out all this infrastructures
so there's still mining the rig's and
and once there they started defaulting
on runs which might take two or three
months and the facility kicks them out
so we think once having hits we're going
to experience this massive difficulty
adjustment because inefficient miners
are going to shut off and we think it
could take maybe May through potentially
July of friction of people shutting off
people wiping out throwing in the towel
and completely shutting off and and
that's when we're gonna actually get
difficulty kicks in and margins are
gonna get better
the efficient miner should not fear have
it they should welcome it their margins
we've analyzed it and we believe that
margins of miners at six cents and lower
running the most efficient equipment
their margins are going to be about the
same pre having and post habit after all
these miners shut off and it's because
they're gonna get the Bitcoin that so
those miners who were run who shut off
about forty percent of them once they
shut off that bitcoins got to go
somewhere it's going to go to the people
that last mining is about survivability
you just need to survive if you survive
difficulty will adjust in the future and
it's gonna it's going to improve your
margins because the people that are
inefficient their Bitcoin is going to go
to you